foreign there's 41 forms of birth  control like why are you getting  pregnant with it like maybe with this  random like I don't understand why these  girls are getting babies left and right  41 forms of birth control yeah but you  can be married get and have a kid that  doesn't mean okay but then but then you  have a duty don't leave would you mean  don't leave women women leave it women  leave  um 70 of the time if they're college  educated they leave 90 of the time  correct women ruin relationships and  they ruin families women women typically  do it actually so if a guy ask the  majority of men their first choice is  not a baby mother just like just like  our first choice typically is not a  short broke guy that's right it's the  same thing it's the same thing